hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich habe heute ein leckeres
türkisches rezept für euch ich mache
nämlich türkische gefüllte teigtaschen
die sind auch bei mir vegetarisch
gefüllt und das ist auch ein ganz
einfacher teig da ist ohne hefe das
heißt man hat keine langen wartezeiten
kann das direkt zu bereiten und daneben
auch weiterverarbeiten und ich zeige
euch jetzt erstmal die zutaten für den
teig und später eben für die füllung
ich brauche für den teig 100 gramm öl
das ist ein sonnenblumenöl 150 gramm
joghurt und zwar ein 35 prozentiger
naturjoghurt ein eiweiß 1 esslöffel
essig 50g zerlassene butter 540 gramm
mehl ein päckchen backpulver 15
teelöffel salz und das eigelb und sich
später dann einfach zum bestreichen
jetzt gehen wir zuerst die flüssigen
zutaten eben die schüssel ihr könnt es
jetzt natürlich auch mit der hand
verkneten
aber mit der küchenmaschine geht es eben
schneller und etwas einfacher also öl
und joghurt rein und ich muss die
flüssigen zutaten übrigens meistens in
gramm ab und zwar aus dem grund weil ich
dann als als ich brauche halt eine
küchenwaage nicht noch ein messbecher
deswegen finde ich das so ganz praktisch
und stellt einfach immer das glas auf
die waage und fülle daneben 1
dann mach das und das eiweiß
so habe ich dann später auch nicht eine
irgendwie im überfluss oder ein eiweiß
deswegen benutze ich dass eine eiweiß im
teig und das eigene leben zum
bestreichen dann noch es sich mit ein
und jetzt schon mal ein teil von mir
so ungefähr bisschen mehr als die hälfte
direkt auch backpulver mit dazu und salz
jetzt lasse ich erst mal kneten und gibt
dann einfach nach und nach so viel mehr
dazu bis es eben ein schöner glatter
teig wird
von der konsistenz her ist der teig
jetzt schön weich und klebt nicht und
jetzt lass ich ihn so einfach noch mal
etwa drei minuten lang verkneten
der tageszweite knete dollar ist schön
weich und ich habe es auch nicht
komplett das ganze mehr gebraucht denn
es kommt einfach immer darauf an wie
groß die eier sind also mal braucht man
etwas wo man braucht mal etwas weniger
da teig sollte auf jeden fall nicht
kleben und ich lasse ihn jetzt ganz kurz
abgedeckt steht und kann ihnen
dazwischen seit schon mal die füllung
vorbereiten
für die füllung brauche ich etwas weiß
ich habe 200 gramm
ihr könnt ja auch gern einen schafskäse
benutzen dann brauche ich etwas lauch
also nicht die ganze lauf stange gerade
so die hälfte etwa ich nehme ein halben
bund petersilie und später zum bestreuen
habe ich mir hier noch ein bisschen
schwarzkümmel zurechtgelegt und das
eigelb von vorhin was ich eben weg
gelegt und jetzt wo sich direkt erstmal
den lauf schneiden und zwar nicht im
ganzen aber ich will es trotzdem einmal
komplett waschen und da kann ich ihnen
einfach im kühlschrank verstauen und das
nächste mal weiter benutzen und dafür
halbiere ich ihnen jetzt einmal hier
dann könnt ihr nämlich auseinander
klappen und hier innen eben auch schön
durch waschen denn des ta ihnen meistens
ziemlich sandig und es mache ich jetzt
ganz kurz hinten unter fließendem wasser
das äußere blatt hatte ich jetzt weg
genommen und dann könnte einfach die
blätter immer schön öffnen und da ihnen
durch waschen
ich schneide mir jetzt hier die hälfte
weg und die hälfte brauche ich jetzt
erstmal nicht und das viertel eigentlich
und hier unten schneide ich mir auch die
dunkelgrünen blätter weg denn diese
meistens ziemlich bitter und vor allem
sind sie ziemlich hart deswegen den ganz
dunklen teil im weg
den muss übrigens nicht wegschmeißen
sondern ihr könnt zur reste auch
benutzen um zb selber gemüsebrühe
herzustellen oder einfach ein bisschen
geschmack der suppe reinzukriegen und
dann können wir dir einfach nach dem
kochen wieder entfernen also das muss
man nicht unbedingt immer wegschmeißen
sondern kann es einfach weiter benutzen
und den rest schneidet ist schön klein
und jetzt noch die petersilie fein
hacken ihr könnt übrigens weniger etwas
lauch zuviel habt einfach den lauf in
einer schüssel verpacken und einfrieren
und dann bei bedarf einfach wieder
benutzen
das gleiche gilt auch für die petersilie
jetzt muss ich nur aus dem käse
zerkleinern
das mache ich jetzt kurz so mit dem
handy einfach so ein bisschen sagt
rücken
und ihr könnt ihr übrigens auch eine
andere stellung nehmen zum beispiel auch
was mit oliven finde ich auch ganz
lecker aber ich habe mir jetzt gedacht
ich nehme die kiesfüllung weil ich ein
ganz großer käse fan bin
aber ihr könnt auch wirklich alles
mögliche nehmen auch eine fülle mit
hackfleisch zum beispiel oder mit
kartoffeln je nachdem was ihr da gerne
isst
jetzt fahre ich noch die zutaten
miteinander ich habe übrigens auch schon
ein rezept auf meinem blog für eine
leckere kartoffel führung
das verlinkt ich euch einfach unten in
der video beschreiben
mit den kompletten lauf das wird mir
sonst bisschen zu viel
jetzt noch ein bisschen verrühren
ich habe jetzt hier bereits ein
backblech zurechtgelegt mit einer
wachstum und jetzt kann ich den teig
ausrollen
aber mache ich das jetzt einfach mit
einem ausbaustopp und etwas mehr
aufnimmt aber erstmal nur die hälfte
jetzt so etwa zwei bis drei millimeter
dünn ausrollen
und jetzt schneide ich den teig in
rechtecke entweder macht er das so mit
einem messer oder in ihm durch so einen
teig für oder torten portionierer das
mache ich jetzt ein spalter quadrate
raus die haben dann also diesen 5 auf 5
cm groß
und dann scheide ich einmal noch durch
weil das ja nur an zeichnen und ich muss
sie eben noch durch schnell
und dann haben wir so schöne
gleichmäßige quadrate
das setzt sich jetzt immer so ein
teelöffel voll von der füllung drauf
so ein bisschen in die mitte damit die
ränder schön frei bleiben
die
und jetzt falls ich sie noch zusammen
und drückt die dreiecke dann zu
und damit die ränder schön verschlossen
bleiben können wir jetzt in einer gabel
den rand eindrücken
so gehen die ränder nicht auf und der
käse kann dennoch nicht auslaufen
und jetzt kann sie mit dem eigelb
bestreichen
das habe ich vorher einfach so ein
bisschen verrührt und dann bestreut sie
mit einem schwarz kümmern
und so werden die teigtaschen jetzt im
vorgeheizten backofen bei etwa 200 grad
ober und unterhitze für ungefähr 20
minuten gebacken
ihr müsst einfach schauen wenn die
oberfläche schönen gold wird nämlich die
heraus und zeigt euch dann das ergebnis
die teigtaschen sind jetzt gebacken und
ich habe etwas abkühlen lassen und ich
werde sie jetzt hier auf so einer
schieferplatte servieren denn es ist ja
im prinzip so was wie fingerfood man
kann sie eigentlich den fingern essen
braucht kein messer und keine gabel mit
dazu und man kann es auch zum beispiel
für ein party berichten denn man kann
die teigtaschen warm und kalt essen also
das finde ich ganz praktisch man kann
super gut vorbereiten und von der
konsistenz her dass ich kann euch mal 1
öffnen von der konsistenz als in sehr
knusprig sieht man auch hier und dann
eben diese leckere führung mit drin
sie sind zwar knusprig aber eben nicht
trocken durch diese saftige füllung und
die finde ich deswegen so toll ich habe
jetzt übrigens ein gleich nicht gebacken
und red hat mir das aufgehoben habe ein
bisschen eingepackt und frischhaltefolie
und wird es später dann einfach noch mit
bestreichen und aufbacken weil ich heute
abend noch versucht krieg und da möchte
ich sie warm servieren
und jetzt gibt es die kalt so zum
zwischen snack und das finde ich eben
richtig klasse
und wenn ihr das rezept nach machen
wollt geht einfach auf meinem blog auf
sallys - blog.de da stehen dann noch mal
die genauen mengenangaben und ich freue
mich wenn er das rezept nach macht und
deswegen sind beim letzten mal wieder
noch nicht